by 2039 the world will look and feel
very different the rate of change is
itself speeding up and twenty years from
now how I will have shifted dramatically
so who might be up and who might be down
twenty years from now
let me take you on a journey of
possibles up Africa a rapidly increasing
population could fuel Africa's surging
economic growth with a pool of young
better educated and globally connected
workers but the biggest revolution in
Africa might be the spread of vast super
arrays a far cheaper solar panels to
quote one energy guru the world will
have learnt to put solar panels where
the Sun actually shines also up China
the super power after cornering many of
the world's vital raw materials could it
now control both its own people and many
other countries struggling to repay its
loans could we see a world where China
exerts its influence through movies and
music too but if there are winners which
countries could be losers by 2039 down
perhaps most of Europe financial
services and banking will be
overwhelmingly driven by AI so Europe
loses much of its global edge parents
who once urged children to become
lawyers and doctors begged them to
become designers artists even actors
anything creative not easily done by
robots down but not out the United
States of America eclipsed by China and
paying a price for getting late to wind
and solar also down the middle east
largely ignored internationally because
no one needs its oil and gas anymore
so what commodities could be driving the
future in 2039 fossil fuels have become
the new forbidden fruit oil has lost
most of its value alternative fuels plus
a collapse and the use of plastics has
seen to that water clean water will be
more precious than ever
water wars have replaced oil wars along
the Nile or any mighty river conflicts
could break out a state closest to the
sea fight those further upstream accused
of taking too much
water data however will be king by 2039
more and more is being bought and sold
mostly illegally and in secret all
governments will rely on data as the
method of control some countries will
have followed the Scandinavian lead by
choosing near total transparency of tax
returns earnings lifestyles to reduce
the secret data threat and more and more
citizens everywhere could be fighting
back
becoming data refuseniks fed up with the
negative effects of social media will
they simply abandon cyberspace wherever
they can
minimizing their electronic footprint
even reverting to writing and delivering
private messages by hand